I think you're being a little extreme
here mr. Belvedere we have a very long
waiting list yep
I'll be happy to have any vodka it was a
tough trip we have sorry I'm fine I'm
fine
just give me one thing you throw some
water on the on the unlock you are
stretching I'm gonna get out of here
great go do your thing can you do your
thing oh I'll tell II do my thinking
you're not gonna question um hey um I
heard what you think is correct did you
just [ __ ] your pants
beware of one who throws stones there's
no reason to go so extreme mr. Belvedere
we have a very long waiting list oh this
is gonna be great for the DVD but equity
we need to make the movie your aunt is
it no cam you get a little bit of
irritable bowel going on well we got
this ready there's no reason to go this
extreme mr. Belvedere we have a very
long waiting list if there's been some
kind of misunderstanding then I don't
need a lecture I know I don't have any
children okay but it doesn't stop me
from appreciating the fact that they
need to eat to live so just me that's my
right
thousand dollars just for tiles is that
plain okay you're there I'll strut
around with my kill my effect I don't
want you why didn't you tell me that
didn't you tell me that bad what we have
built this right at the airport just
relax okay you're not gonna drown if I
did drown I'm floor out of town what do
you wanna do that all do the peacock yes
the peacock you said I'm just pissed
good actually filming at the airport
stinks I'm going that's okay
the peacock you thought you push her
into me you are touching the whole body
needs to be touching mine that's how I
know you're straight right Jason yep
what
sorry noise tricky even if I wasn't I'm
100% human I try to act that way so just
mine site because we need this figure he
needs a leader we need vision ready
that's what I'm talking look he's
farting I mean I don't know look where
he will go
that's wrong I'm talking about let's do
it we got it